the flames from california's wildfires
didn't come within 30 miles of celine
zazuetta's home
but for her family they've still been
life-changing emma has asthma
her sister isabella has allergies all
made almost unbearable
by the choking smoke that this year has
turned the city skies to this
day after day of appalling air quality
for millions of people
it's like walking into an oven when you
feel the heat and you feel the air and
the
dirty air it's been overwhelming i could
see it in my in my children
exceeding their health it's been
alarming
and it's very scary the fires
from other cities they
they're just getting closer to us i feel
like
it is making my lungs like bad
and it's heartbreaking to see her not
being able to enjoy life like other
children would like children without
asthma
but with this air quality it's affecting
every child
they live in a part of california
already known as america's asthma
alley even before the fires smog was a
fact of life here but
smoke blanketing thousands of miles has
made it a population wide issue
doctors say the pandemic keeping
children indoors has helped but
a future of toxins is alarming it's a
hard thing to accept the thought of
having children exposed to more
pollutants we've been working so hard
through the years to really decrease the
amount of pollutants children are
exposed to and really have worked hard
on the air quality to have a new
type of air pollution coming in is
heartbreaking to me it's a step
backwards and that makes me sad
and all this talk about air quality is
happening at a time when
because of these things we know more
than ever before about
what's actually out there a host of new
apps have appeared to give us air
quality readings wherever we are
the us government's own includes the air
quality index
for days the readings were in the
hazardous range in oregon
they were off the scale in the 700s
the result researchers say is that
hundreds possibly thousands of people
have died prematurely due to the air
quality
there's a fair amount of evidence
worldwide that air pollution
actually is quite a significant uh risk
factor for early death
and if you look at the numbers it is one
of the
top leading causes of death worldwide so
the fact that we have
these intense smoke episodes and that
essentially pushes some
very susceptible people over the edge as
it were is not surprising to me
for now this country's led by a man who
denies the science
about why fires are intensifying it'll
start getting cooler
i would just you just watch i wish
science agreed with you
hey well i don't think science knows
actually we know his successor does
believe the science
and has ambitious climate plans but that
this is a problem
that's getting worse is clear for
everyone to see
greg milam sky news los angeles